hey 42 here the doomsday clock is a
symbolic representation
of how close we humans are to wiping
ourselves
out of existence it isn't meant as a
kind of accurate countdown but is a
metaphor for the general peril humanity
is facing
at any given time with midnight
representing
our total annihilation the clock was
originally set in 1947 not long after
the end of the second world war
when things were looking fairly dicey
two years previously
atomic bombs had been dropped on the
japanese cities of hiroshima
and nagasaki and nuclear tensions were
continuing to rise
to reflect the dire situation the
doomsday clock was set
at seven minutes to midnight in the
intervening decades the time on the
clock has been reset
24 times to reflect the differing
existential danger humanity has found
itself in
today thanks to the continued threat of
nuclear war
and the rapid advance of climate change
combined with what doomsday scientists
call
cyber information warfare the clock is
set
at 100 seconds to midnight meaning
that never before in human history or at
least since 1947
have we been closer to our own
destruction
as a species that's why it's never been
more relevant to ask ourselves
the totally not ridiculous question
could two people
sole survivors of some great global
catastrophe
repopulate the earth maybe it'll be an
asteroid strike perhaps nuclear war
or rogue gay eyes whatever the cause if
you were to find yourself as one half of
the last couple on earth
would it be possible for you and your
new best friend
to rebuild the human race from scratch
assuming all the important bits survived
the apocalypse in full working order
and after the inevitable i wouldn't
sleep with you if you were the last man
on earth
jokes had ceased being funny making the
first generation
ought to be no problem at all if you
wanted to get things off to a
particularly good start you could even
have a go at breaking the record for the
most number of children produced by a
single couple
that's 69 by the way set by randy
russians mr and mrs vasilyev
back in the 18th century though i think
that was less about saving the human
race and more to do with the fact that
they somehow
produced 16 pairs of twins seven
sets of triplets and four sets of
quadruplets
as well as the fact that condoms of the
day were typically made out of
animal intestines and were
unsurprisingly
not all that popular so far
so good then but as you may have
predicted things are going to get pretty
tricky from here on in
there's no way of getting around it that
first generation of post-apocalyptic
survivors
your children will all be brothers and
sisters
and that means making generation number
two is going to require
some pretty serious incest at least
you're only going to have to give the
dreaded
birds and bees talk once it was
legendary founding father of
psychoanalyst
sigmund freud who named incest as one of
the two
universal taboos i guess cersei and
jaime didn't get the memo on that one
but lannisters aside the incest taboo
turns out to hold remarkably true
and every single human society around
the world practices it
in some form or another though the exact
rules on which family members it's okay
to get jiggy with
change from culture to culture some
scientists believe
this inbreeding avoidance behavior is
essentially
hardwired into us that we're simply born
with an instinctive and deep aversion to
the idea of
incestuous relationships and that would
make sense
because whilst i'm confident that
everyone watching this video
finds the thought of sexual relations
with their close relatives
utterly repulsive that isn't the only
reason you should be avoiding it
inbreeding is also downright
dangerous to understand why we need to
take a look at our genes
the human genome project was an
international research effort to
determine the sequence of the human
genome
and identify the genes that it contains
amongst its many achievements
it's estimated that we humans have
between 20
and 30 000 genes apiece
we have two copies of each of our genes
one inherited from our father
and one from our mother and mutations in
some of these genes are responsible for
nasty inherited diseases like
cystic fibrosis sickle cell anemia and
tay
sachs disease but the majority of the
worst inherited diseases
are recessive that means that you'll
only actually have the disease if you
inherit the same gene mutation
from both your mother and your father
which makes sense when you think about
it
if a dominant trait caused very serious
defects
it would most likely die out by having
children with a close
relative say a sibling with whom you
share about half of your dna
you dramatically increase the chances
that your offspring
would have two copies of any potentially
damaging genes
that happen to be knocking around in
your dna
the average person has around two of
those by the way so that's a quick look
at the science
but what happens when we see inbreeding
in action
in the real world the island of pinglab
is a tiny atoll in micronesia
back in 1775 it was devastated by a huge
typhoon which left only 20 survivors
of those survivors the island's king
whose name i will not butcher in this
video
suffered from a very rare syndrome
called complete achromatopsia
which leaves those who have it
completely unable to see
colour today one in 10 people on ping
lap suffers from the disease
that might not sound like much but just
one in
33 000 people suffer from it in the
general population
this is an example of what is known as
the founder effect
the loss of genetic variation that
occurs
when a new population is established
from only a small number
of initial founders now i have no doubt
that complete color blindness sucks
you can forget about a career in snooker
for a start
but inbreeding can have far far deadlier
effects than that
remember there were 20 survivors of the
typhoon on pinglab which means nobody
was being forced to have babies with
their sister or brother
in order to repopulate the island if
they were
things would probably have been much
worse
because the more closely related two
people are
the more dangerous inbreeding becomes
one study from czechoslovakia carried
out between 1933 and 1970
found that of children who were born to
parents who were first
degree relatives that is parents or
siblings
40 percent were severely handicapped and
of those died young it's also thought
that inbreeding was responsible for
killing goff
one of europe's great royal dynasties
the habsburgs the habsburgs ruled over
austria
not to mention half of europe at one
time or another
for almost 650 years but like many
people who have a taste of power they
were
very very keen to hang on to it
in a truly extreme version of what
happens in the family stays in the
family
the habsburgs were notorious for
arranging
strategic marriages within their own
family
tree uncles married nieces cousins
married other cousins
and just about everyone committed incest
like it was going out of fashion
despite all our riches lands and wealth
the habsburgs weren't the prettiest
bunch
take a look at one of the many portraits
that were painted of their endless kings
and you'll probably noticed most had one
thing in common
a chin of truly epic proportions
the condition which caused this facial
abnormality
is known as prognathism or more
fittingly
habsburg's jaw and it was extremely
widespread in the family due to
inbreeding
but generations of cousin-on-cousin
action
caused much more than just incurable
ugliness
and the chin like a sledgehammer step
forward
charles ii of spain also known as
charles the bewitched
aside from being the son of royalty
charles's life didn't get off
to a great start for one thing his
mother was also his father's niece
and his grandmother was also his aunt
in fact thanks to generations of
consanguineous marriages
that's inbreeding to you and me charles
ii
was genetically speaking more inbred
than the offspring of two siblings would
be
as well as that distinctive habsburg's
jaw which was said to be so severe that
charles had trouble eating and speaking
poor charles is forced to have suffered
from several genetic conditions
including combined pituitary hormone
deficiency
and renal tubular acidosis he didn't
learn to speak until he was four years
old
and by the time he was six he had
measles chickenpox
rubella and smallpox as an adult it said
that he was so spectacularly ugly
that he scared his own wife but charles
was the last male of his line
so the habsburgs were naturally keen to
make sure
he left an heir unfortunately neither of
his two marriages
produced a child and this despite
charles carrying out
his doctor's advice to sleep in the same
bed
as the corpse of his father in order to
improve his fertility
how that master plan failed to work i
guess we'll never know
but try as they might nowhere ever
arrived
having said that being as charles's
autopsy would eventually reveal that he
had only
a single atrophied testicle that was and
i quote
black as a lump of coal that probably
shouldn't come
as too much of a surprise ultimately
charles was to be the last of the
habsburgs monarchs in spain and his
death in november 1700
led to the war of the spanish succession
as half of europe fought over the scraps
of the world's greatest inbred empire
looking a little further back in history
we meet
the neanderthals one of our closest
human relatives who last
walked the earth about 40 000 years ago
for a long time it was thought that we
or at least
our ancestors were responsible for
killing off
our broad brown cousins why
anthropologists commonly assume
that despite having smaller brains us
homo sapiens
were a far smarter bunch and were able
to outwit neanderthals
using intelligence and planning to steal
both their food sources and their lives
but whilst that may be partly true we
are the earth's biggest bullies after
all
recent evidence suggests that
neanderthals might simply have been
unable to avoid inbreeding due to their
relatively small
population size and hence they shacked
themselves
out of existence so what does all of
this
incest based doom and gloom mean for our
post-apocalyptic
couple bravely plugging away in their
attempts to repopulate planet earth
sadly chances are it's all going to end
in tears
and atrophy testicles now i'd forgive
you for thinking that all of this is a
completely pointless and hypothetical
question to ask
in the first place the doomsday clock
may well suggest that catastrophe is
nigh but it seems pretty unlikely that
such an event would conveniently leave
some kind of neo adam and eve behind
to get busy starting the world's most
disturbing family
but actually the threat to our existence
from imminent catastrophe
is the very reason all of this stuff
is relevant it's fair to say
we're pretty much all in on planet earth
we haven't just put all of our human
eggs in the blue planet
basket we've stashed the chickens the
hen house and a whole damn farm in there
too
if something does go wrong on earth an
asteroid strike for example
we as a species are essentially
[ __ ] and if we really are according to
the doomsday clock just
100 seconds away from such a disaster
it would be a pretty good idea for us to
spread the hell out
as soon as possible nuclear war might
well wipe out life on earth
but if we could establish a handy couple
of colony planets
out there amongst the stars we'd have an
insurance policy in place
the problem is there aren't any other
habitable planets nearby and by
habitable i mean
earth-like there's mars of course but
that will require revolutionary
terraforming technology
that we don't yet possess if we want to
actually
live on the surface that is and not in
artificial
bubble-esque environments the nearest
star to our own proxima centauri
is 4.2 light years away just to put that
number into the kind of perspective
our tiny human minds are capable of
understanding
that's around 25 trillion miles
the current furthest man-made object
from earth is the voyager 1 space probe
that was launched by nasa in 1977
the probe street clean out of our solar
system
back in 2012 and as of march 2020
it's made it a respectable 13.8 billion
miles from earth
unfortunately that is only about 1
800th of the way to proxima centauri
at that rate it would need another 77
000 years or so
to make it the rest of the way
technology has improved since the days
of voyager 1
and nasa's juno probe that swung by
jupiter in 2016
got up to about 165 000 miles an hour
that kind of speed would bring our trip
to proxima centauri down to about 17 000
years
and assuming this kind of technology
continues to advance rapidly
it may not be too long before we're
ready to send a new colony spaceship
out into the stars but such a ship would
undoubtedly
need to house its precious cargo of
interstellar explorers for
many many generations which is exactly
why scientists need to know how many
people it would take
to maintain a healthy population
with a sufficiently diverse gene pool
that could one day
repopulate an entire planet it's a
question
that might one day secure the survival
of our very species
so what's the answer well
according to astrophysicist frederick
marin for a six thousand year journey to
proxima centauri
in a shiny new space arc you would need
a minimum
of 98 individuals though it's worth
pointing out that similar studies have
reached wildly different conclusions
some suggest we would need tens of
thousands of people for such a trip
to be a success before i go
i want to leave you all with a little
thought experiment
have you ever wondered how many
ancestors
you have i'm willing to bet it's
something that's never really crossed
your mind
but working it out should be easy right
you have two parents
four grandparents eight great
grandparents
and sixteen great-great-grandparents
that's 30 ancestors so far
all we need to know is how many
generations there are in total
and we should have the answer but the
mathematically minded amongst you
may be beginning to nervously finger
your calculators
because the number of your ancestors
appears to be doubling
with every generation and anyone who's
ever heard of the rice and chess board
problem
will know that this kind of exponential
growth
can't be good by this method doubling
as we go from one generation to the next
you would have
just over a trillion ancestors after 40
generations
approximately the last millennium of
human history
a trillion ancestors for reference is
around 1 000
times more humans than have existed
ever and that's just 40 generations
of an estimated 7 000.
so what are we missing i'm glad you
asked because
as you can see the numbers simply don't
add up here
nature must have taken a few shortcuts
during your ancestral history
to break that exponential growth
somewhere
well it certainly has done and the
answer
is quite simple when you think about it
every single person alive today is
related
we're all part of the same giant
family tree meaning we all have
many many shared ancestors
or to put it another way and if we're
prepared to stretch the meaning of the
word
just a tiny bit you their 42 viewer
are inbred you're welcome and thanks for
watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me you can do that
by joining the 42 club here on youtube
by clicking the join button below
or heading on over to patreon thank you
you can also get your hands on a first
edition signed copy of my new book
sticker flag in it
by heading on over to unbound publishing
the links in the description
and pre-ordering your copy today